oh yeah my favorite look at them 2015
was the last time we saw Justin
Timberlake and Jimmy Fallon performed
the history of rap on this night show
and since Justin's making history
performing at this accrual for now the
third time we know it's gonna be good oh
you know it but we can't celebrate JD's
future without looking back at his
colorful past it was so good any two is
there for a lot of it Keltie night has
the story of when we first met Justin
[Applause]
[Music]
minam Titus
[Music]
[Applause]
and I was like 12 my arms are still too
long but they were really long whenever
I get a chance I like to play golf you
know one of my favorite sports
it's called adolescence and it's painful
for all of us and look I mean you can
reference a lot of my bad hair days
because they were on different red
carpets what do you think of the hair
what was the inspiration you're going on
sore so I figured do something that's
easy to perform easy to dance with so
that's that's all I did
yeah I got a new haircut yep Zippity doo
dah I used to dream about this when I
was a little boy elms I was always the
type of young person who's very
determined to do something I didn't know
what I was gonna do I was gonna do
something and music I found all roads
led back to that
[Music]
his first TV appearance was as a cowboy
hat and boots we're an 11 year old on
Star Search but we first met Justin
Timberlake when he was 17
sporting curly bleached blonde hair and
singing with NSYNC you might be Haiti
this is Justin from NSYNC and you are
behind the scenes of our new video it's
gonna be me it's gonna be May we're
actually inside the toy store and makeup
for like four hours
we loved him and NSYNC but in 1999
Justin rocked our world when he hooked
up with Britney Spears we're really good
friends we worked with each other on the
Mickey Mouse Club me and him and JC
[Music]
weird you know lucky individuals to get
to do something that we love to do I
couldn't be more you didn't she he
really is funny
in 2002 Justin and Britney broke up and
our matching denim dreams were crushed
the reason
rumor is that Britt cheated on him with
her choreographer Justin admitted he
cried himself to sleep after the split
then came the rebound relationships
first up Alyssa Milano little bit dating
around 2003 was the start of an over 3
year relationship with Cameron Diaz even
after the breakup the two remained
friends they start in the comedy bad
teacher together you ripped away I think
so too
as it turns out we just still think the
world of each other had a great
experience together okay well what are
you gonna do to entertain
[Music]
after this steamy music video of course
there were rumors JT got with ScarJo
nothing was ever confirmed though and
then in 2007 he found his future wife
Jessica Biel did you watch him on the
meet sure
I mean I don't really remember but I'm
sure I've had 36 years old JT is a total
triple threat you can sing he can dance
and he can act Justin's got ten Grammys
and four Emmys thanks to guest starring
on SNL I'm just a little bit confused
with the dancers give me some more I
don't hate winning in 2008 Justin took a
break from music and focused on acting
one of his first films was alpha dog JT
got a bunch of tats and went super lean
for the role
wait cardboard for three wants that's
what made me sign up actually the fact
that I got to take my shirt off so much
I've been told me one that you get the
scoop on the Facebook is cool that's
what it's not going for yeah from the
social network to friends with benefits
we noticed one thing about lots of JT's
films he likes to show off his body and
we are not complaining
one bit
[Music]
but the best role ever just might be
family man
thanks to two-year-old Silas he's
hitting his terrible twos a little early
so we're hoping he'll get out of them a
little early now seeing this guy as
hashtag hot husband and dad yep life
sure has changed since we first met
Cheston really see yourself in ten years
older possibly wiser not for sure but
older I don't know I'm still waiting to
see if the higher powers will ever let
me reproduce because uh you know I'm a
slacker I don't know I just basically
boss them around all the time do this
fix that make God take the garbage out
he says
like every woman is of Justin Justin
like America's coolest guy so no George
Clooney is America's coolest guy whose
secondary right there all I got in my
head is cornrows and frosted tips it's a
good thing we showed you that boat